Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Today is day 32.
We're talking about holiness as empowerment.
This is something that's frequently forgotten in the discussion of holiness.
Sometimes holiness is pictured or is talked about
as if it is only a withdrawal from other
things, and from worldly things, and even from culture
itself.
But actually, holiness is highly missionary.
It is highly missional. One of the ways we know that holiness
has come
is a response to the mission of God.
Let me give you a couple of examples of this, okay?
So in Isaiah chapter six, remember that foundational
passage about the holiness of God where Isaiah says, "In the year that
King Uzziah died, I saw the Lord high and exalted,
and he was seated on a throne, and the train of his robe filled the temple." And he
talks about the seraphim, the burning ones, that were calling out,
"Holy, holy, holy." He sees this vision of God's holiness, and
he immediately cries out and says, "Oh, that's not me.
I'm not holy like that. I'm a man of unclean lips." And then
he is cleansed. His lips are touched and cleansed and purged.
We talked about that a few days ago, a few weeks ago.
And then he says, this is very interesting.
The angel comes and says, "This has touched your lips.
Your guilt is taken away." This is verse seven.
"And your sin is atoned for."
And then verse eight, "Then I heard the voice of the Lord
saying, 'Whom shall I send? And who will go for
us?'
And I said, 'Here am I. Send me.'"
Now, this is a tremendous idea because for
huge swaths of the Middle Ages, people
felt like holiness meant withdrawing from life,
withdrawing from culture, shutting themselves in a monastery, and
that was the epitome, the peak of holiness.
You had all these other people who, eh, they might've been right with God, but the
most holy ones were the ones who slept on stone slabs in hair
shirts and ate a poor meal and
didn't do anything. Just all the time, they just stared at their belly button all
the time and contemplated their own spiritual life.
And that isn't true.
That's not true at all. Instead, it's almost exactly the
opposite here. It's like, "Now you're holy." "Oh, can I go?"
Right? To become closer to
holiness is to become closer to the heart of what God loves
and who he is, and God is inherently
missionary.
In his essence and in his mission toward the world, he
is always about the display of his gospel.
So it's entirely natural then that when Isaiah
becomes more holy like God, that he becomes more missionary,
right? There's a modern version of this in
some circles.
I use the word fundamentalist. I'm not trying to shoot at anybody.
In some circles, it's like holiness means
greater separation from everything, and we don't touch people, and we don't get
close to people. We hold hands in our churches looking inward, and
it's us four and no more in a holy huddle.
And I would just say, no. No, that's not holiness.
That's not holiness because holiness means I get more like God,
who is always active in the world.
Jesus was the exact opposite of all of
those people, those Pharisees. They were
mad because they couldn't match the simplicity and the
separation with which he lived his life, right?
He was always out there and always with people and
shows up at these parties that they're like .
And he's touched by these people, and he touches others, and
they're saying, "Oh, this is horrible." And he says,
"My holiness isn't separating me from the world.
It's separating me from sin."
And the Pharisees couldn't match that
because they were separated from the world, but they had taken their idols into
their heart. Now, Acts chapter two, a really
similar thing. So they're gathered together.
The people of God, the disciples, they're gathered together, and
there's a sound like a rushing, mighty wind and
the flames of fire. And later, Peter looks back on it and he says,
"What happened was God purified our hearts by faith." That's Acts 15:8 and
9. So when God purifies their heart by faith, they
become more holy. They become like God.
He cleanses them further, like we talked about a few days ago.
And then what happens next?
Well, they spill out of the room. Rather than just being like,
"This is so great. We're all so holy.
Let's just gather around and hold hands and look at one another and sing
kumbaya." Instead, the doors burst
open, and they spill out into the world, and they go out there, and they
start proclaiming the news of Jesus. Why?
Because to be holy is to be empowered and bold
to be like God in his missionary stance toward the world.
So in your holiness-- By the way, same thing happens in
Acts chapter four. I can't take time to do all of them, but in Acts
chapter four, they're under persecution, and they get back together, and they're
filled with the Holy Spirit, right?
They're under powerful, special, new measures of control by the
Holy Spirit. And what happens? They spoke the word of God with boldness,
right? Don't forget this part. When we talk about
holiness as purity, that's beautiful and right and essential,
but holiness is also empowerment, and to be more like God
is to be more like a missionary all the time.
So that's part of the picture of holiness, and I had to make sure you got that one
on the way by, all right? We'll talk to you tomorrow.